bonjour diane montrose dont jean maurice
il ya le temps et bonjour aux auditrices
et auditeurs de martinique 1ère la
présidente du comité de soutien françois
fillon qui était avec nous nous parlons
forcément de cette primaire de la droite
et du centre des 19 et 26 novembre dans
notre idole montrose la campagne sur le
terrain est très peu visible en
martinique comment vous l'expliquez
écoutez je pense que ça c'est ce que
vous pensez c'est ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui nous avons sept candidats
pour ces primaires pour les élections
nous avons quatre comités de soutien en
martinique
celui différents comités de soutien dont
je suis l'une l'une des représentantes
pour la martinique et nous avons des
comités qui travaille comme un peu plus
nos agents des comités qui aujourd'hui
organise des réunions publiques nous
avons des comités qui organise o'shea
des réunions chez l'habitant
nous avons des comités qui utilise aussi
tous les moyens et les médias je dirais
un peu moderne les réseaux sociaux
sociaux pour faire aujourd'hui campagne
je crois que nous avons quatre comités
actifs qui travaillait de manière
différente alors difficile de faire
campagne lorsque son poulain a sorti sa
petite phrase qui n'est vraiment pas
passé à la fin du mois d'août celle de
françois fillon sur l'esclavagé
l'occasion de partager la culture
française en vous le reproche cela
lorsque vous faites campagne sur le
terrain on va travers les réseaux
sociaux ou non écoutez pas du tout je
crois que et d'ailleurs je m'attendais à
cette question et je vous ai ramené le
discours de de sablé-sur-sarthe du 28
août de françois fillon
je veux dire deux choses françois fillon
dit la france n'a pas inventé lé
esclavage il dit une deuxième chose
effectivement il parle du partage de la
culture lire c'est un mauvais procès que
de penser que françois fillon
aujourd'hui est un raciste je veux quand
même rappeler gelé rappeler des gens
bien a simplement mais je veux que même
les deux clubs patients et celui au
milieu de la partie quand même françois
fillon est celui aujourd'hui qui n'a pas
hésité lorsqu'il a été élu à sablé sur
sarthe
en tant que plus jeune député français à
27 ans à mettre à l'honneur raphaël
elizé qui était le premier maire noir de
sablé
ce programme si aujourd'hui vous lisez
le programme de françois fillon
et si vous prenez son abécédaire
françois fillon dit une chose il dit il
n'y a pas de france l'autre mère fait
partie de la france et nous devons nous
souvenir du de la contribution de
l'outre-mer et de la contribution des
martiniquaises et des martiniquaises des
martiniquais lors de nos guerres et
c'est pour cela que françois fillon
considère que la france atteint devoir
envers les autres maires dont je crois
qu'aujourd'hui l'interprétation qui a
été donnée n'est certainement pas la
bonne
or ce n'est pas pas dit un mot d'origine
la photo de françois fillon est demandé
de voter pour lui lors de la primaire du
centre et de la droite
écoutez je crois qu'aujourd'hui françois
fillon à un programme qui est l'un des
meilleurs programmes
françois fillon a travaillé son
programme pendant trois ans il s'est pas
réveillé un bon matin en se disant oh ça
serait bien que je que j'aille à la
campagne présidentielle françois fillon
est un homme aujourd'hui qui a le
courage de dire la vérité aux français
au martiniquaise et aux martiniquais et
je pense que les martiniquais et les
martiniquais savent aujourd'hui qu'il ne
s'agit pas d'un show alors nous avons eu
de très bons comédiens au discours
fumeux l'émoi président jeu je pense que
les martiniquaises les martiniquais
savent aujourd'hui qu'il ne s'agit pas
descendu moi je dis que c'est donc et je
pourrais nous rappeler le discours de
françois fillon
ce n'est pas le discours de françois
fillon françois fillon dit aujourd'hui
qu'il a été premier ministre sous la
mandature de nicolas sarkozy la preuve
de loyauté et il est allé jusqu'au bout
de sa mission pas de loyauté vis-à-vis
de nicolas sarkozy mais de loyauté
vis-à-vis de la france dont il a été
jusqu'au bout de sa mission
et c'est justement parce qu'il a été un
premier ministre qu'il sait aujourd'hui
quelles sont les limites du système
et c'est parce qu'il a été premier
ministre qu'il sait aujourd'hui que pour
réformer la france pour transporter pour
transformer la france
il s'agit pas d'être premier ministre
mais il faut être le capitaine à la
barre alors le document d'alain juppé
quand une quarantaine de pages de serait
ce que pour son programme
sa vision qu'il a de nos pays françois
fillon j'ai pas vu grand chose avec un
petit chapitre ne serait-ce que marquée
outre mer j'ai peut être mal lu alors je
pense que je vais vous inviter encore
une fois à aller sur le site de françois
fillon et plus exactement sur
l'abécédaire qui est sur ce site avec
les 50 mots clés de la campagne de
françois fillon comme et des 50 mots
clés à la lettre o comme outre-mer
françois fillon dit la chose suivante je
ne considère pas comme ce qui a toujours
été fait aujourd'hui l'autre mère comme
une charge et donc si je ne considère
pas l'outre-mer comme une charge
il ne s'agit pas de parc et l'outre-mer
dans un petit ministère où on donne la
charge de l'outre-mer à un ministre et
puis comme ça on s'en débarrasse
mais en fait ce que l'affichage
l'outre-mer leur usure fini je ne dis
pas que la rue oudinot ça sera fini mais
la méthode sera différente l'outre-mer
c'est la france il n'y a pas de france
aurait pu y est alors cette première en
france et il y à aussi la loutre mer
fait partie de la france est aujourd'hui
ce taux françois fillon dit c'est que la
méthode sera radicalement différente
parce que justement la martinique c'est
la france lorsqu'il s'agira aujourd'hui
d'appliquer des réformes ou de nouvelles
propositions de loi il y aura ce qu'on
appelle la concertation de l'outre-mer
qui se fera avant la promulgation avant
la proposition de la loi pour faire en
sorte que ces propositions tiennent
compte des spécificités de l'outre-mer
alors sinon quand les si l'on en croit
les sondages parus ne serait-ce que ce
matin face aux filons est à créditer de
10 à 15% des intentions de votes
enregistrés en fait le troisième le
troisième homme ne serait pas qualifié
pour le second tour ce sera un peu le
faiseur de roi est ce que vous dial
montrose vous suivrez les consignes
qu'ils donneraient éventuellement en cas
de second tour ce qu'est ce que je peux
vous dire il y a aujourd'hui ce que les
médias disent que les sondages disent et
puis aujourd'hui il ya la campagne sur
le terrain en tout cas quand je vois
françois fillon dans ses déplacements
sur le terrain
je crois que les salles sont pleines il
y a le terrain et puis il ya le show
médiatique ottomanisme morphiniques je
veux dire et je vous dirais
qu'aujourd'hui en martinique nous
faisons campagne nous faisons compagne
de manière différente
nous faisons campagne en utilisant
effectivement tous les tous les réseaux
sociaux et tout tous les moyens je
dirais moderne qui nous sont donnés mais
nous avons aussi rendez vous vendredi
avec la population nous ne faisons
peut-être pas des réunions publiques
parce que je crois qu'aujourd'hui une
entrevue vendredi ça sera à l'instant
food à fort de france
mais je crois qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
d'expliquer il s'agit aujourd'hui de
convaincre
il s'agit aujourd'hui de détailler le
programme il s'agit pas d'un show je
crois qu on a vécu un quinquennat
catastrophique et je crois qu'il faut
avoir le courage de dire la vérité aux
français
si on ne dit pas aujourd'hui à aux
martiniquais aux martiniquais et si on
dit pas aux français et aux françaises
que la france est dans un état
catastrophique et que notre pays est un
pays très endettés et qu'il est bien
joué
il prévoit tout un programme pour
réduire ce déficit de la france
notamment auprès des collectivités
locales
le programme de réduction de d'économies
de 20 milliards d'euros concernant les
collectivités locales au moment où ces
collectivités
il s'agit pas osé il s'agit pas d'un
programme aujourd'hui qui je crois qu'il
faut poser la question autrement au
martiniquaise aucun martiniquais
si nous disons aux martiniquais que tous
les quinze jours
nous prêtons sur les marchés pour payer
la dette de la france pour payer
aujourd'hui l'endettement de la france
eh bien je crois qu'on comprend qui
aujourd'hui fait un prêt pour payer sa
facture d'eau sa facture d'électricité
et son loyer
aujourd'hui la france est un pays
endetté qui va droit dans le mur et à la
voix de bronze d'argent au saut du lit
les locales et bien bien évidemment
qu'il y aura de moins en moins d'argent
pour les collectivités de conseillère
territoriale il n'y a pas aujourd'hui un
candidat qui s'attelle aux vrais
problèmes de la france
nous ne pouvons pas avoir 98 5 % de nos
richesses
qui servent à couvrir la dette de la
france quand est ce qu'on va s'attaquer
aux vrais problèmes et bien françois
fillon le dit aujourd'hui l'une des
premières mesures
c'est de diminuer l'endettement de la
france sans ça les collectivités locales
que nous sommes ne pourront pas espérer
à plus de dotations et aujourd'hui le
problème de l'emploi
quand on parle des 6 millions de
chômeurs est ce qu'on pense vraiment que
l'avenir des 6 millions de chômeurs eh
bien écoutez c'est l'emploi public non
l'avenir pour l'enseignant et chômeurs
oui les gars et le privé donc il faut
faire le nécessaire pour qu'il y ait un
cercle vertueux autour de l'emploi vient
montrer nos jeunes nos deux millions de
jeunes en france qui sont sans emploi
puisse aujourd'hui ça sert et est ce que
vous faites campagne auprès de vos
camarades ceux avec qui vous avez fait
signe un pacte de gestion pour la
collectivité territoriale martinez
qu'est ce que vous leur dites tiens vous
pourriez par exemple participer à cette
primaire de la droite et du centre en
signant mais bien évidemment puisque la
primaire de la daurade visant à masquer
l oms on reconnaîtrait dans des valeurs
de la droite on se reconnaît dans les
valeurs républicaines soir parle de
déroute se reconnaît dans les valeurs
républicaines mais bien niveau des
redevances est informé que rod et moi
j'en parle partout j'en parle
y compris à mes collègues je leur en
parle non pas parce qu'il s'agit
aujourd'hui simplement d'une histoire de
partis politiques mais aujourd'hui si on
prend la mesure de la situation de la
france nous ne pouvons pas rester muet
que nous soyons de la droite du centre
de la gauche ou que sais-je aujourd'hui
les martiniquais et les martiniquais
doivent s'exprimer sur cette
présidentielle parce que nous venons de
vivre un cac et la catastrophe une
dernière question répondez moi oui ou
non vous serez candidate pour les
législatives
non monsieur viol ton j'aurais pas
aujourd'hui d'ambition de candidature
pour les législatives
d'accord j'ai bien entendu merci des
montres aux mercer nous est présidente
du comité de soutien à françois fillon